well combine X avid fans before we get
into this DLC and ski me thus being sort
of people been freaking out today Jeff
first of all what do you think about
more common X and the Pantheon the
Mortal Kombat games how is it I like it
I think it's it's something that's you
know it's really hard to follow up on
the last game because the last game is a
reboot that is retailing the parts of
the story that you care about with the
characters you care about you know kind
of the the last game was just mortal
kombat 1 through 3 served at you again
and that's rad so naturally anything
going past that is just got a really
hard act to follow and they bungled it
last time in MK 4 and 5 and 7 and 8 all
the other stuff and shadow mux was cool
but um you know they're doing a much
better job this time around that they
did in like the ps2 and Xbox era with
their story and in terms of like
characters they're creating is new
characters and just you know what
they're doing to the fighting and stuff
like that it's a it's derivative of the
last game a lot of ways and like how it
plays and stuff like that but it's it
feels good the new characters are cool I
remember you guys had Ed Boon on that
the show one of your live shows last
year you talked on the bombcast later on
a bed head like they're gonna bring in
all these a sort of children of other
characters and whatnot yeah how does
that feed into the story like is it is
it a good story should you care about
the story dimona combat game ultimately
the story's all right so that yes the
the there are eight new characters for
our kind of the good guys and then for
our kind of bad guys and the four good
guys kind of traipse around and are in
the right place the right time and the
bulk of the story like the book of the
pivots in the story kind of seems to
hang on those for just descendants of
old fighters and towards the end of it
it gets a little like Wesley Crusher for
my taste where they're just like they're
they're doing all the heavy lifting and
you're like I kind of like scorpion yeah
I can see page is cool but scorpions a
crazy hell demon with the mess and it's
stuff so yeah I like ken cheese son
takeda probably best out of the new
characters the new those four characters
from a story perspective or from a
fighting force maybe both both yeah and
then Aaron black I think it's probably
the best new character like gameplay
wise I think he's pretty cool
shifting from the story to the gameplay
the book of that game is beating the
living [ __ ] out of people at how have
you been enjoying a Peter oh it's good
you asked me that because I don't really
care that much my mortal kombat story
will try to give this one a shake didn't
love it but as a fighting game I do
really like it it has you know all these
sort of layered mechanics that you would
hope for that give people sort of you
want strategies and you know ways to
fight and it succeeds at that pretty
well like I haven't noticed any balance
issues or anything like that and it's
fun to play it's it's not as stiff in my
experience as previous the last mortal
kombat game so that's great for me
because that was one thing that was
always a turn off and now I find myself
able to kind of get into the flow a
little bit easier even if I haven't
already mastered a character I need to
make a point of clarification though go
for it which camera do I have which is
me right here last week on the lobby I
said something about gore and mortal
kombat wishing there could have been an
option to turn it off that doesn't mean
I don't like the gore I just want to
clarify that right now before you guys
jump on me in the comments before were
you goes live in a couple days can you
turn off the gore now one of the core
well I think that there are a lot of
things moral Kombat offers that are
beyond the gore yeah great fighting game
you know and if you want to look at the
story mode you can say this fantastical
world that is filled with crazy
characters and maybe some people would
be upset at the gore I'm not going to
knock the game for not having an option
to turn it off I think it could benefit
from it but because it doesn't have it
that doesn't detract from that stuff but
if you play the game a lot right the
only scene where good as you said the
only seen outside of fighting where
there's like explicit like really bad
gore is a scene where someone's about to
be beheaded the gore always is just sort
of like next to everything in this game
it's not part of the universe as much
and unless I'm misremembering series but
but yeah like you don't see stuff like
this in the story mode you know it just
sort of seems yeah you don't actually
you can't do fatalities in the fights in
story mode right okay it doesn't give
you the option yeah so it's all it's all
just like tacked on and that's fine but
what that says to me is that you could
still have this game without that for
someone who doesn't want well what do
you Matt the xrays I mean the x-rays are
you know the ultra moves basically they
do a lot of damage and in some cases
those are as violent as a lot of the
fatalities oh I'd say more
because you get that sort of the
slowdown in that moment of impacting you
hear the person like Moe let's slow down
slow pitches oh so painful but like I
find that I find the stuff entertaining
like yeah it's shocking but that's kind
of what it is right so anyway I just
want to point that out doors because I
feel like it could be him so differently
doesn't mean I don't like that's what
they did they seem to be showing off
like obviously this is the stuff that
looks best in trailers look best in
gameplay they were like teasing at all
these fatalities and what characters in
the game and what not what is the loop
of MORTAL KOMBAT I you unlocking
characters are you when looking
unlocking the fatalities because like in
the previous game that the classic
Mortal Kombat thing was always the
discovery of like the move sets to
discovery of the fatalities and then the
Internet age that doesn't mean anything
anymore yeah so what are you actually
doing Jeff to like as you're going
through the game like what is the new
content call me through is it just about
your playthrough the story mode there
are a lot of different ways to play
there are random modifiers you can
deploy this like quick uppercut recovery
or you know you have infinite super
metering the other guys none and just
like weird stuff like that you can do to
kind of alter the game but in terms of
just like progression like you've got
your character level you're leveling up
in gaining XP you get your faction level
there's a whole faction metagame or when
you first boot it up you pick one of
five factions and all of your stuff
contributes to that faction and then as
you level up in that faction you gain
access to faction kills which are like
short fatalities that are all Universal
they're not character-specific their
factions specific and those almost look
like old MK fatalities where it's like I
chopped him in half and then didn't
follow it up like and then diced him up
in you know so those feel like classic
in a weird way and then you're also
running coins to unlock stuff in the
crypt which they've had time and time
again this time the Crypt is a little
bit crazier you have an inventory you
find items and but you're still
generally just unlocking like a lot of
concept art and music but also costumes
the motions to do the additional
finishers okay executive tech
mortalities yeah brutality is the other
that's the other news but you also you
also get those awards right yes yeah you
can get so yeah you build your get their
combat card your background your titles
and other stuff right like butter yeah
but those have buffs associated with
them some of
unlock by just like leveling up they'll
be like I'm level 50 in my I love I am I
am level 50 in the Lin Kuei okay thank
you and so I can get action did you pick
White Lotus okay no see you know I was
gonna pass judgment but I was like
that's not the right thing to do he's a
good guy I'll respect his choice like
way old man you dump it on me think
we're all day no that's quite all Drake
lesson learned god dammit day seems tape
hey hey was over he's not anymore he was
number one in the link way really I was
number two Wow sorry Tay Tay's link way
all day well yeah and so yeah you're
you're leveling up that stuff but yeah
you're also building so there a bus
associated with so the border you equip
on your little like nameplate right they
can give you additional coins to unlock
more stuff in the crypt and give you
additional faction XP or you know
depending on what you equip so you kind
of build those things accordingly to
what you're trying to work towards at
any point to these sort of you know
talking about a lot of unlockables
summer cosmetic some are you use them in
combat extra fatalities and stuff at any
point does that feel like a like a legit
carrot on a stick to keep playing or you
you basically just need the core
motivation to enjoy the combat and want
to continue fighting to stay interested
I don't know like it mortal kombat is
one of those games like because the lore
has been so loved by people over the
years and you know people are drawn in
by the fatalities and then sometimes
they find more there to like i think
that that's led to a situation where you
have a lot of people coming to mortal
kombat that are not big fighting game
players so yeah I'm kind of in that
company yeah yeah all I modern Mortal
Kombat game you know it so it's great
that they have this big long story mode
and even if it isn't as long or as good
as the last one it's still great that
they're doing that because they're
they're kind of providing something for
that type of player yeah but generally
speaking to stick with it for a real
length of time you're going to want to
care about the fighting you can care
about it at multiple levels you can you
know to go try to be in tournaments and
try to do all that stuff or you can just
find a group of friends that are all
around the same skill level and enjoy it
on that on that level 2 I think it can
work kind of across the board there but
you know you kind of have to care enough
about the fighting to to make to make it
last let's talk about the coins for the
second i was talking to you this morning
I'm about this that when you guys were
playing it seemed to be like pretty fast
you're getting a lot of coins
you're unlocking stuff in the crypt add
the since has been like a patch kamesh
since people had a lot of people are
talking about the Sun serif and so so
when we got discs the patch there was a
patch already live on the ps4 so you put
it into patches just like any other game
would one has a patch it hasn't done a
hard patch like that sense but there are
a lot of numbers and variables that they
can adjust without shipping a proper
like ps4 right past they told me there
was a patch that was rebalancing story
yeah exactly so so yes originally story
mode was actually way harder than it is
now really okay and so they can make
balance changes on the fly as well so
like the tournament they had last
weekend you know some people discover
their like there's some stuff in there
that like is out of balance mmm they can
make those balance Corrections without
having to go push your console patch
process and QA and also stuff they can
tweak the numbers ship it out so it's
possible that they could tweak the
numbers on how many coins you get out of
things yeah that's the story right now
but I like one sixteenth of the coins
that you used to get but it's unverified
like it's a thing that I'm actually
going to go after the lobby you go check
out with an unpatched version of the
game like keep the ps4 offline see what
I can do and match that up but the
bigger problem is that you know you earn
coins and these coins you use to spend
in the crypt to unlock you know all
these tombs whatever that have something
behind them but you don't know what you
really have no way of I disabled
everyone sure like yes there will be a
fact that says here are the you know 100
crypts in here that you should actually
open cuz they give me something gameplay
relevant right and then here's the stuff
it's all concept art like that mk9 was
the same way yeah and so when you when
you play story mode like you know
they'll give you chunks of coins like in
the beginning you do kind of go in there
and you can walk around and spend some
stuff you know get some new things when
you're in the Crypt itself you find new
items that unlock new areas though give
you a like here is like 10,000 coins and
but all that doesn't really add up to a
lot when a lot of like there are
probably a hundred or more 100 i think
is an underestimation these tombs and
some of them are like seven thousand you
know six thousand when there's so many
of those ultimately you get to the point
where the game stops like holding your
hand and you have to start earning those
coins you really don't earn that many
coins by just playing
any of the modes really yeah which is a
big change from MK 9 like clearing the
story mode and MK 9 gave you enough
coins to probably unlock half the crib
really if you were doing it right now
because some of them you open up you get
more coins when you wake up something so
if you're you're picking right and know
what you're looking for play for the
story mode you can get everything you
want and they've been pretty aggressive
with their DLC stuff I remember seeing
you playing last week in this Henry a
picture of Goro writer mainly thing on
the screen is filthy purchase Goro so
the filthy thing is that so that that's
the if they did do this patch to reduce
the number of coins they're selling
unlock the entire crypt for twenty bucks
right right and that's how the opposite
gay meeting start out of the game remote
a laptop power on top of the season pass
yeah being story mode on loud me to lock
less than ten percent of what is in the
entire crypt oh wow so i would have to
play this game ad nauseam to unlock
things i don't really know what they are
right and when it's a piece of shitty
fan art that you feel like a dick you
feel like you've just been screwed with
ya and so yeah so for them to offer this
is kind of an incentive look oh cool
like i just bypass all that but then you
got a factor in like okay well what if
you want the characters that are coming
with this game right right you're going
to be dropping 50 bucks to like for the
four characters too well there's a few
characters in the game that have move
sets that have AI that really should be
here anyway you have to pay is Baraka is
like in the game right there is a [ __ ]
there's a lot of content right now you
pay a lot of money for to access and the
game is just out and that feels really
shitty hmm especially when you're
fighting these characters in some sense
and it's like well they're here yeah
like Goro was the pre-order bonus and is
also theoretically available for sale
like when I hit on the PlayStation 4 you
just it just it just says push X to
purchase Goro right on the character
select screen when you try to select him
and it takes you to the store but the
store the item to buy actually is live
yet so I can't buy um I mean at least
when I checked this morning yeah maybe
it's finally fixed but so it was just a
pre-order bonus I got a code for it and
unlock Goro the other problem is on the
ps4 i downloaded Goro at home there's no
way to download Goro right now oh so I
came in and tried to download again like
don't do it all right you go to the ps4
library go to like you know hit the the
mortal kombat x thing it says to add ons
I
but like I usually show the list the
game screen and like my ad no longer
show so I was able to download the blue
steel sub-zero scan that uh again he
paid 12 bucks two bucks great but said
that one's a little they're putting some
money into the prize pool for like the
ESL finals or something like that it's
like ok he's a little Esther or not was
that clear at purchase point i don't
know if it's in that text or not they've
said it they've said as much get that
samurai pass samurai pack only comes
with the the season pass yeah i mean i
just feel like they could have made it
easier for you to feel rewarded for your
skill while playing this game to then
enjoy unlocking things in the crypt
rather than making it a slog to the
point where you feel like you know what
i don't care i'm just going to pay 20
bucks and feel like a sucker hmm and I'm
never going to do that but that's the
stuff that you can you know there will
be a fact that says here's where the
stuff that you should care about in the
crypt is and you should just take that
route and the unlock we need to unlock
to me the the kind of sad part about all
is like you know games get over
monetized I actually like this game and
it's over monetized in a weird way and
for me like the this the spiritual kind
of crushing thing is the easy fatalities
right yeah so that's something you find
some of them in the crypt and they're
consumable items that let you just they
actually it's it's the dev controls you
would hold block and hit triangle to do
a fatality or two square or square to do
a fatality and when the game is a
development that's just how it was yeah
and that's been like that I think in in
previous games well where it's just like
that's they have easy fatalities on
during development so that they can show
it at e3 and quickly show people I
tality and all that sort of stuff so
every time I play the game prior to
release that was how you did the
fatalities and now they're in there is a
consumable item not only like his things
you find the critics like whatever if
you find them in the game like you know
you don't need no but then he's like
tokens for them yeah yeah they will sell
them to you you buy 30 45 bucks you can
so the Garrity the game s consumables
for mechanic mechanic that you can just
be just did that like presumably like an
action replay or something would have a
lot in the past what or that would have
been a cheat code in the game yeah
previous is different than just like
additional content right this is
actually something that they're
providing you and then taking
essentially keeping guarded yeah right
and then it's you don't come across
I'm very often in the game so you kind
of get that taste and I mean what the
hell the fatalities not that difficult
either so it's a situation where I was
like there's no II don't really get a
taste like I did I use one like me like
they give them to you right list of
people who may be sure to be a she right
yeah like they have that option but then
it's sort of taken its taken away
because there's like eight or whatever I
mean why is it that the game has to do
that to you why can't you just have the
option any time if that's the way you
want to do your fatality like if I can
just like just go full on old man here
first go for it I'd love it we used to
just pass scraps of paper scrawled
fatalities and stuff back and forth in
an arcade like you Prince print stuff
out eventually like the internet became
enough of a thing that's like I was like
skipping school to print out supposedly
a fatality is a stick and go to the
pizza place and see which one's worked
in which ones didn't and then report
back and go now these are all fake and
then strategy guides came along and it
became like well now as an official
strategy guide you can buy and get all
the stuff like the secrets are kind of
gone hmm but you didn't have to buy the
strategy guide you could still go
through that process and be on the
internet and do this sort of stuff and
now it's a consumable item that you can
do it cheat code style for five bucks
for 30 and like crystal brand you like
about his fans exactly so for a series
that's so entrenched like something like
evolved when it gets knocked for dlc
you're like both the modern it's a
product of a modern ear yeah exactly
like Mortal Kombat is a game that you
would think is popular enough to sell
numbers without being nickel and dime to
definitely yes and as Beth is like would
such a core fanbase yeah and it's like I
like what's on the disk like if you're
asked if you asked me like you know hey
sixty dollars for this yeah like review
this what do you think like that it's
cool you know it has some issues it
didn't doesn't hit quite as hard as the
last game did they made some
improvements to the fighting and that's
great but then it's like all this little
stuff around it and you have to go out
of your way to avoid it like you would
at every single turn yes by that I
couldn't believe them a menu with the
shot oh it's an after you've already
bought that stuff that things still are
you getting rid of there
letely every bit of dlc yeah just right
of the overall store and so yeah like
Mortal Kombat should be better than this
yeah it should be able to kind of stay
above this kind of nasty stuff but but
here it is it's a bummer